sont capables de mieux tenir un budget sur le mois.
Ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que nous n'avons pas changé la somme qu'ils recevaient,
uniquement l'environnement dans lequel ils comprenaient leurs revenus.
De tels indices environnementaux ont une incidence.
Je ne vais pas partager des astuces que vous connaissez déjà.
Je ne vais pas vous dire d'ouvrir un compte d'épargne
ou d'économiser pour votre retraite.
Je vais partager des astuces sur comment combler l'écart
entre vos intentions d'épargne
et vos actions.
Êtes-vous prêt ?
Voici la première :
exploitez le pouvoir du pré-engagement.
Fondamentalement, nous nous voyons de deux façons différentes :
notre moi présent et notre moi futur.
Dans le futur, nous sommes parfaits.
Dans le futur, nous économiserons pour la retraite,
nous perdrons du poids,
nous appellerons plus nos parents.
Mais nous oublions souvent que notre moi futur
est exactement la même personne que notre moi présent.
Un des meilleurs moments pour épargner est lors de la déclaration fiscale.
Nous avons fait un test A/B.
Dans le premier groupe, nous avons envoyé un message début février,
avant même qu'ils aient déclaré leurs revenus.
Nous leur avons demandé
quel pourcentage ils économiseraient sur un remboursement des impôts.
C'est une question très difficile.
Ils ignoraient s'ils en recevraient un et quelle somme ils recevraient.
Mais nous avons posé la question.
Dans le second groupe, nous avons demandé aux gens juste après le remboursement :
« Quel pourcentage souhaitez-vous épargner ? »
Voici ce qu'il s'est passé.
Dans le deuxième cas, quand les gens venaient de recevoir le remboursement,
ils voulaient épargner environ 17% de leur remboursement.
Mais quand nous avons demandé aux gens
avant qu'ils ne remplissent leur déclaration d'impôts,
le taux d'épargne est passé de 17% à 27%
en demandant en février.
Pourquoi ?
Car vous vous engagez pour votre futur moi
et bien sûr, votre futur moi peut épargner 27%.
Ces importants changements de comportement
viennent d'un changement de l'environnement de prise de décision.
Nous voulons que vous puissiez exploiter cette force.
Prenez un moment
et pensez à comment vous pouvez vous engager pour votre moi futur
pour quelque chose qui, vous le savez, sera un peu difficile.
Utilisez une appli vous laissant prendre des décisions d'épargne en avance.
L'astuce est qu'il vous faut un contrat qui vous engage.
Deux : utilisez les moments de transition à votre avantage.
Nous avons expérimenté avec un site
qui aide les adultes âgés à partager leur logement.
Il y a eu deux pubs sur les réseaux sociaux
ciblant la même population de gens de 64 ans.
Dans un groupe, nous disions : « Vous vieillissez.
Prêt pour la retraite ?
La colocation peut aider. »
Dans le second groupe, nous avons été plus spécifiques :
« Vous avez 64 ans et vous allez sur vos 65 ans.
Prêt pour la retraite ?
La colocation peut aider. »
Dans ce second groupe,
nous soulignons le fait qu'une transition est en cours.
Tout à coup,
nous avons vu le taux de clics et d'engagement augmenter,
en soulignant cela.
En psychologie, cela s'appelle « l'effet du nouveau départ ».
Que ce soit au début d'une nouvelle année ou saison,
votre motivation à agir s'accroît.
Inscrivez une demande de réunion dans votre agenda
pour le jour avant votre anniversaire.
Identifiez un objectif financier.
Et engagez-vous-y.
La troisième et dernière astuce :
maîtrisez les petits achats courants.
Nous avons mené différentes études
et découvert que l'achat que les gens disent regretter le plus,
après les frais bancaires,
c'est de manger dehors.
C'est un achat courant que nous faisons presque chaque jour
et c'est une mort à petit feu.
Un café par-ci, un burrito par-là ...
Cela s'additionne et réduit notre capacité à économiser.
Quand je vivais à New York,
j'ai regardé mes dépenses
et j'ai vu que j'avais dépensé plus de 2 000 dollars
sur des applis de covoiturage.
C'était plus que mon loyer à New York.
Je me suis promis de changer cela.
Le mois suivant, j'ai encore dépensé 2 000 dollars --
pas de changement car l'information seule n'a pas changé mon comportement.
Je n'avais pas changé mon environnement.
Après avoir dépensé 4 000 dollars, j'ai fait deux choses.
J'ai supprimé ma carte de débit
de mes applis de covoiturage.
J'y ai mis une carte de débit n'ayant que 300 dollars par mois.
Si j'avais besoin de plus,
je devais ajouter une nouvelle carte
et nous savons que chaque clic, chaque barrière,
change notre comportement.
Nous ne sommes pas des machines.
Nous n'avons pas un boulier au quotidien
pour faire la somme de nos dépenses en comparaison à ce que nous voulions.
Mais nos cerveaux savent très bien
compter le nombre de fois où nous avons fait quelque chose.
Je me suis donné une limite.
Je ne peux utiliser une appli de covoiturage que trois fois par semaine.
Cela m'a forcée à restreindre mes déplacements.
J'ai pris le contrôle de mes dépenses de covoiturage au profit de mon mari
du fait des changements environnementaux.
Prenez le contrôle de cette dépense
et changez votre environnement pour qu'elle soit plus difficile.
Voilà mes astuces.
Mais souvenez-vous d'une chose.
En tant qu'êtres humains, nous pouvons être irrationnels concernant l'épargne,
les dépenses et les budgets.
Mais heureusement, nous le savons
et nous pouvons prévoir comment nous agirons dans certains environnements.
Faisons cela avec les économies.
Changeons notre environnement pour aider notre moi futur.